you know it's not easy being me right
not only am ia gamer the most oppressed
group on the Internet I'm also PewDiePie
oppressed by mainstream media left and
right
I fought all these battles and Here I am
getting attacked when when I'm at the
weakest finally I have met my match
t-series is taking over
it's inevitable at this point hashtag
beauty pie is over party
it's just what oppression feels like is
this what it means then I don't like it
okay so let's look at other people being
oppressed so I can feel better about
myself yes of course I'm talking about
tumblr in action so we can look at other
people having a hard life and feel
better about ourselves oppressed by H&M
mirrors this is so sad dear hmm this
image of two mirrors in your store on
the right meds my normal affection
reflection on the left you can clearly
see I'm I'm shorter and fatter
oppression dear hmm as you can see from
these photos the perspective or the
reflections make me look bigger if I'm
closer to the object how does this work
dear H&M can you please fix the laws of
physics this is so sad this kid
literally brought a jug of water to
class and it's just drinking out of it I
hate college and I hate [ __ ] now the
question here is do they hate them
separately alright
or do they hate them individually
collectively because of this person you
know it's not really clear imagine
imagine coming home from from college
you're still living at a home you come
in really bad mood your parents are like
honey what happened you wouldn't believe
mom my day is ruined
so when drank water
a jug your mama says they're shocked I
hate white people too good job you know
suddenly me complaining about t-series
doesn't feel so bad what else do we have
becoming disabled by choice trans abled
what no people are becoming disabled on
purpose and calling themselves trans
able why does this exist who came up
with this it's a mental illness yeah I
must be a methylone then apple emoji
finally acknowledged that women work out
too this makes me hate the world like
why does this exist stop it
this is not real this is not real can we
well god it's real oh hi makes me sick
women run lift weights and surf and they
finally finally this giant company that
I buy my overpriced cell phone folks
acknowledge the fact that women exercise
this is a big day this is amazing we
truly run out of things to celebrate I
didn't know what I was gonna find today
but this is this is beautiful
motherboard another fantastic new media
website guess how many women Elon Musk
followers on Twitter pinned
same number of people currently on Mars
I use Twitter for news organizations my
insta has same women as men this is not
real this can't be real no no no oh my
god I thought I thought the articles of
me were petty but this is just this is
just next-level it's not a real thing
are you do
a bit I can't tell a question mark the
term spirit animal is deeply religious
and is and using it is cultural
appropriation
please use petronas instead okay all
right all right I've read it it's
already made me laugh let me explain it
art made started he was fed up with his
sisters candles from before bling oral
flowery smelly so he created man cans
with candles that smell like campfire
and coffee and he made them out of soup
cans so he would donate the soup to
homeless people while still selling the
kids the candles and he sold 80,000 of
them which means 80,000 people got a
meal and Tumblr's take on this is I'm
not behind this still a white bow read
boy reinforcing gender stereotypes I
don't give a crap how good of a person
he is I'm pretty sure there are some
rare is out there who have donated to
charities ever done something good
Hitler's family probably thought he was
a great person misogyny still beside you
did you just compare a 17 year old boy
who fed their homeless to Hitler tumbler
everyone wrote pro tip is that there's a
pro tip for you guys all right this is a
pro tip from the tumblr verse don't
learn a language if you do not come from
the languages bearers ie don't learn
French if you're not French during lunch
I knees if you're not Chinese don't
learn Icelandic if you're not Icelandic
it's just appropriate culture or what
would be ideal here if everyone just
stayed away from each other at all times
okay
that must be a whoosh isn't it it's a
whoosh then I just get whooshed there
must be a joke right
this can't be real but everything else
has been real
and it's from tumblr tell me I can't
make jokes about themselves Hey they say
it as well you know what's messed up
about the cultural appropriation
nonsense it's just ridiculous I can't
tell if it's satire per sergeant
maintain that hurt well this actually
kind of makes sense okay so here's the
difference between social activists and
social justice warriors social activists
oh look there's no wheelchair ramps in
that building let's build a ramp social
justice warrior let's persecute the
people using the stairs and make them
feel bad for having legs how dare you
have legs
don't you see these stairs you're not
thinking about the trans able people how
are they gonna walk up these stairs when
they remove their legs huh you tell me
you disgusting look I know I never want
to pull out my I have a comparative
Women's Studies degree centered in black
feminist and war monologist woman
womanist ideology with a concentration
in media debate language out on y'all
but y'all be pushing me there don't make
her pull out her useless degree again is
it real is it real
it's a comparative Women's Studies
degree centered in black feminist woman
are womanist womanist
ideology with concentration in media I
have so many questions I'm just confused
where are these people where are they I
never see them I just see them online
this is gender neutral this is gender
neutral this is possibly the farthest
away you can get from Jenner nutri I
just like this comment saying I'm
raising my baby chaotic neutral because
they're the most interest
it's a vago not feminine why are there
so many gay men who don't date a woman
just because she has a [ __ ] on it like
that is stupid discrimination we're so
deep into social justice that being gay
is now discrimination we did it gang we
finally came full circle full circle and
beyond oh my god this video I saw it
I think mean Ethan were the reason this
video were pulled because after our
video we reviewed it and it got deleted
YouTube pulls controversial music video
with graphic homosexual sex after a
break the 700,000 views controversial
let's see let me see if I get it it's a
controversial video with graphics tech
but it's totally normal video with the
women almost naked dancing sensual moves
then it's okay
no they literally eat each other's
poopoo that's controversial try to make
tryna write a joke that won't offend
anyone on tumblr this is the worst point
I have ever seen if you have trouble
making jokes and races everybody
misogyny Z then you are funny actually
do you want to build a snow person fine
alright maybe T series is taking over my
channel isn't such a big deal after all
smash subscribe so we can take over the
Indians no oppression intended okay I'm
sorry but we can't let them win smash
subscribe so we can still be the biggest
most subscribed channel on YouTube leave
a like if you enjoyed this video and I
will see you tomorrow with another video
what's he gonna come up with next you're
just gonna have to find out tomorrow see
you then
bye
[Music]
you